good morning Hank it's Tuesday so you've
started a lot of businesses crash course
scishow dftba records VidCon the
ceaseless juggernaut that is 2d glasses
I think your companies employ dozens of
people none of whom worked for the
federally mandated minimum wage of $7.25
per hour but I can't imagine that your
next project is a fast-food restaurant
corndogs and sodium what impact would
raising the federal minimum wage have on
you and your employees at first glance
it seems like a no-brainer any minimum
wage is terrible both for corndogs and
sodium and for its employees think on
one-on-one argument goes like this the
free market is going to set wages where
they need to be like if you want to pay
five dollars an hour for corndogs and
sodium employees but no one takes the
job for five dollars an hour you're
gonna have to pay more you'll increase
your wages until you can attract the
kind of employees that you need to you
know batter and fry and serve encased
cast off pig meat and we know that
economies tend to grow less when
government set and control prices so
higher minimum wages restrict economic
growth plus unemployment will go up
because the minimum wage is $10 per hour
corndogs and sodium can only afford to
hire one person but if there was an
unrestricted wage market than they could
attract to people who'd be willing to
work for $5 an hour each so in the end
setting a minimum wage is an attempt to
alleviate poverty that actually
increases it however Hank surprisingly
enough it turns out that actual labor
markets are a lot more complex than the
models of labor markets created by
college freshmen this brings us to a
famous study by two economist David card
and Alan Krueger so in 1992 the state of
New Jersey raised its minimum wage 18.8%
Pennsylvania right next door did not
raise its minimum wage card and Krueger
had the bright idea to go to the border
of New Jersey in Pennsylvania and do
employment surveys on either side of it
and what they found is that restaurant
employment in New Jersey actually
increased when the minimum wage went up
since then a bunch of other studies have
confirmed card and Krueger's findings
while some have found that there
actually are negative effects to
employment when you raise the minimum
wage although it's surprisingly and
consistently mild why well a bunch of
reasons for one the minimum wage is
probably near where the market would set
it but also low wage workers tend to
spend most of their pay raises which
leads to increased economic activity
which in turn leads to more jobs and
higher wages also mean less turnover
which leads to lower costs of training
and hiring and firing on the downside
higher wages are also associated with
higher price
on goods and services that rely on
low-wage labor which means that your
corndogs Hank would probably be a little
bit more expensive I think the larger
question is whether raising the minimum
wage actually reduces poverty and on
that front there is growing consensus
that at least in the medium run it does
a number of big recent studies have
shown that raising the minimum wage 10%
reduces the number of people in poverty
by about 2.5 percent even many opponents
of the minimum wage acknowledge this but
it's important to note that like that
won't always work at some point raising
the minimum wage will lead to inflation
and slower job creation it's just not
clear where that point is but it's just
as disingenuous to call the minimum wage
a job killer as it is to say that the
minimum wage is gonna fix economic
inequality in short Hank in economics
there's no such thing as a free lunch
but when it comes to reducing poverty
without affecting employment higher
minimum wages seem at least to be the
cheapest lunch available but ultimately
now that I'm I guess an employer I'm
more persuaded by the personal argument
we found that paying a living wage which
we would do even if we open corndogs and
sodium leads to happier more productive
employees I know that's hard to quantify
but it's also what's allowed VidCon and
dftba records to retain employees for
years and years and grow sustainably
thank office Lee I am NOT an economist
although I did win a bronze medal in
economics at the Alabama State I could
even Decathlon tournament in 1993 but
our strategy has worked out pretty well
for us so far and it's also working at
much larger companies like Costco Hank
the United States is a rich country and
I think there's a growing body of
evidence that the US doesn't benefit
from having poor workers of course
raising the minimum wage isn't gonna fix
that problem but I hope at least we can
begin to have a nuanced conversation
about the problem heck I'll see you on
Friday